we're gonna be talking today about uh
youtube stuff
i i guess twitter stuff and twitter
stuff just well i think there's been a
few
recent interesting things that have
happened but i think as we all recorded
we are yeah we're recording i think
we're like this because we're having a
bit of a two-week break of recording so
this is going to be like six weeks from
when we talk yeah
this will be all news by the time you
guys are seeing it yeah yeah
but um yeah so as of us recording this i
think
was it two days ago uh youtube the the
official twitter account on youtube uh
announced uh an interesting update
they are testing to see whether they
should get just get rid while testing
which when youtube starts to test
something 90 of the time it goes through
yeah so
they are testing to see if it's worth
getting rid of the dislike button wait
not getting rid of it but getting rid of
getting rid of how many dislikes
i've publicly seen on the video
essentially yeah yeah i hope they
it's gonna be real awkward if they
revert it by the time this comes out
i mean i just hope i mean i mean even if
they revert it i i do want them to
i i i will sell on the record now that i
think it's a [ __ ] stupid idea oh
so just in recent memory what's the only
things i can recall that youtube
backpedaled on was the verification
thing where
verification thing yeah a year and a
half ago or two years ago they were like
um no one's verified anymore and that's
right only select channels can be
verified
i think it's like only music channels
right well yeah but it was like there
was only
like like the i people with like 10
million subscribers weren't
like eligible or something and it was
like well who the [ __ ] can be verified
um there was that and then there was the
youtube heroes which is the
infamous oh my god oh my [ __ ] god
i've completely forgotten about that
that was something like last year wasn't
it
that was like four years what was what
was youtube heroes again
especially where they were gonna like
let people be like moderators
in a way oh yeah that was their answer
to like
well i mean as the heroes of anime um
you know
yeah but there's just been i don't know
i feel especially with like these
we were talking about it before this
podcast started but i feel that when
youtube
suggests a change or an implementation
to this system it's not so much a
suggestion it's more like
hey so no one asked for this and uh
we're going to tell you
right before it starts happening but
yeah this is what's happening if you
disagree with it
lol sorry they also tested one time as
well like just getting rid of people's
thumbnails like that was the thing
remember that where they were just like
no no no no it was like the animated
thumbnail right right it was like
where the previews i mean nowadays on
youtube i think where it's like
if you hover over a video thumbnail then
it plays like a preview yeah the video
yeah but before
yeah i remember this they were gonna get
rid of the idea of thumbnails and just
replace it with the previews of
thumbnails
i don't know if that was the intention
that could be wrong but i remember there
was a period where i was just logged on
youtube
and everything was moving everything
was moving or there was just no
thumbnails for anything and then
i found out later it was because the
this youtube test that they were doing
on like 0.1 percent it just looked like
it just like looked like you know those
newspapers from harry potter yeah
everything is just moving it's it's just
annoying because every it seems like to
me as a content creator every time
youtube takes one step forward they just
take two steps back
like what was really suss about that
twitter post for me was they were just
like
guys we hear you we hear the creator
feedback we know you asked for this
we are removing the dislike button and
then every creator comes up
and was like yo did you guys ask this
because i didn't ask for this feedback
well because anyone who's making any
content that is like reasonable like
anyone who's
like literally trying to make good stuff
probably isn't afraid of the dislike
button
yeah because you know personally you
know i mean
it might change by this point i've never
had a video that has ever been like
you know less than 90 percent uh more um
yeah less than 90 likes
yeah i mean i i feel like if it is less
than 90 likes
even like either you [ __ ] up or you
got or got recommended to an audience
way outside of your usual audience which
is
uh which is what i noticed but yeah i i
feel like the dislike button
and like the dislike bar at least i i
think it's a really useful resource
yeah and i and i saw because i i
retweeted it with the
uh the fallout everyone disliked this
picture yeah um but
yeah i i was reading through the replies
of that tweet and there were a lot of
really like
interesting points being made being like
you know one of the biggest points i saw
from a lot of big creators
was that well if we get rid of the
dislike bar then how are people going to
judge whether the video is like a spam
a scam or you know something is like
just you know
you don't want to waste your time on a
10 minute video yeah i think i think the
first thing
i think the first thing that came to
mind was for me was tutorial videos
yeah yeah yeah the the first thing
because there are so many useless
[ __ ] tutorial videos
and you know immediately when some when
you click on something and the dislike
bar is like it's a 50 50 ratio you're
just like all right
immediately close immediately close down
go to the next one like back in the day
you know maybe you know maybe you wanted
to you know if you wanted some software
that you probably should have been
paying for
you know i remember that you know the
way that you would judge if it was a
safe way to get it was like all right
this video is lots of comments lots of
likes yeah
yeah yeah i think this is safe you click
on another video it's like get this
software for free and it's like
yeah like 80 dislikes you're like
probably not gonna download that get it
from this will definitely not hack your
computer.com yeah
for me it's it's you know sometimes
[ __ ] windows or some software gets
this random error and you're just
you start googling it and and for some
reason for me i found that
youtube tutorial videos has been more
useful than just googling it and going
into like specific
microsoft forums which is just like from
like six years ago
like and you look at it it's like posted
in 2012 no reply yes it's like cool
thanks
it's no replies or you get about like
try these 10 million
fixers and one of these will possibly
work right but then like
let me just go on tangible yeah that's
[ __ ] [ __ ] as well because
sometimes they'll have like you know
when you have like a problem
that's like very minor and they'll be
like yeah try uninstalling your ram and
gpu and putting it back and
i'm not gonna [ __ ] do that like at
that point i'm giving up yeah i'm
throwing in the trash
yeah but like i i feel that like the way
youtube tutorials work is that you know
you
search up this error code and i put it
on youtube and like there's gonna be one
video that's got a
positive like to this like ratio and 90
of the time
that's the fix i'm looking for yeah yeah
because every other video
is just like 50 50 percent yeah and i
feel like to me that's that's like
legitimately the first thing that came
to mind
yeah about removing dislikes it's
frustrating as well because i think
there have been changes that youtube has
made that like because i mean i think
whenever youtube makes any change they
get [ __ ] like even if it's a good chance
oh yeah of course yeah um
you know and i think they have made some
changes where everyone was [ __ ] on
it
and it started and literally a week
later no one gives a [ __ ] yeah right
like
people like okay i understand why they
did this and it was quite frustrating to
get used to but when they moved the
comments
to like the comments used to be when you
would be on a youtube video like this
one right now you could just scroll in
the comments would be right there at the
bottom
right uh but then they moved it so that
you had to just drop
down and it was right there which at
first
i absolutely hated i thought why would
you do this and then now i'm like
this makes way more sense yeah now that
i've gotten used to it it's streamlined
everything if i want to read the
comments i'll
i'll if i want to just you know i don't
have to scroll through all these [ __ ]
videos you know
i mean i mean if we're going you know
all the way back to the like og times
right like i remember there was a
massive uproar when
youtube changed the you know from the
five-star rating that was dog [ __ ]
anyway
[Music]
i mean i understand as well but uh i
mean i
understand it and i i prefer this new
youtuber yeah
of course but like i remember back in
the day people were like no i'm so used
to like raiding five stars now yeah
youtubers were like well how am i going
to end off the video i used to be able
to say rate five stars but now i gotta
like
ask people to like like smash the like
button that's the like button
i i do think that when they do these
changes as well
like they must have some data on their
end yeah that says this is a good idea
yeah right well yeah it's not completely
baseless i'm sure right which is why
like i wish that they would be like
listen about it this is our idea right
yeah
we're thinking not not be like listen
we're here
i [ __ ] hate that don't [ __ ]
pretend like you're doing
me a solid yeah [ __ ] do anything
don't pretend like you give a [ __ ]
about the people who use your website
thanks corporation my best friend
you want to do me a solid reply to me
when i have a [ __ ] problem
don't [ __ ] tell me that you're
removing dislikes and then he wasn't
[ __ ] doing it anyway and i'm pretty
sure everyone knows they're doing it
because of this because like you know a
bunch of really big names got into
controversy yeah and dislikes play a
really pivotal part
right like because you know i think in
youtube we have this way
where we have like kind of decided that
a youtube or an apology if you will
its success is based on like to dislike
yeah yeah right
so i think that youtube is trying to get
rid of that while we judge your videos
you know quality well i kind of like
that because i mean obviously you know i
wouldn't be saying this if i was on the
receiving end although but as someone
who's seeing
you know i like it i think apologies
it's also cool as well because i
a lot of the times use that as a gauge
to figure out like
the general idea of what the community
thinks about this particular because
sometimes you know when when these
apology videos come out and i'm like
you know it's a good apology i look at
the video and there's like you know 20
000 likes to a hundred thousand dislikes
yeah i'm like whoa why is everyone like
what's that yeah like what if i think
i'm missing something
exactly exactly it like it kind of re i
guess it like re-justifies like oh
do i really fully understand the whole
context of this video because
yeah i might think this is a good
apology video but a hundred thousand
other people disagree
so it's kind of like oh okay well then
maybe i should walk into it more but
also there's just something cathartic
about having the dislike button there
you know this
it just doesn't feel right if you're
just smashing a button and it just
doesn't really mean anything
it's like it's like going on onto a
video right
and just seeing the comments turned off
nothing makes me more like angry than
going on a video and wanting no not even
wanting to comment on it just wanting to
see what other people
think about it yeah and just being
remove that privilege exactly
and i just feel like as well this is
just going to lead to more
shitty comments because if you take away
one avenue
as you know you know we we all saw with
uh oh what is it like
twitter right it's just rationing now
that's that's that's like the new thing
did twitter ever have a dislike button i
don't think it did no no they never had
it
yeah no but i thought they changed they
took um
oh i feel like i feel like rationing is
a recent thing though
is a recent thing yeah yeah why did
rationing start happening i think it's
because
we want to explain what rationing is
like i've talked to several people and
they've not known what ratio is
well ratio oh i mean on twitter yeah
it's just basically like where
if if a tweet is so bad right you'll
know it's an awful tweet
when there'll be like more replies than
likes and that's that's called rationing
because you're oh like the ratio is so
much higher to call it
more of a reply to the original tweet
has more likes than the
yeah exactly exactly it's like both
either ways right
yeah i feel like you know if there's
likes on the video people are just going
to start rating in the comments
oh yes they're just going to like up the
one talking [ __ ] yeah yeah but
but on youtube you can delete the
comments as well right exactly i i don't
know it just seems like a stupid idea i
don't know that's the thing right
yeah that's the thing right and and i
think that's why it's such a big problem
for people because i think a lot of
youtubers realize that
because creators can and have the space
to delete comments if they want to and
delete like hateful
you know hurtful negatives should be
able to which you should be able to
don't get me wrong
yeah but you know you can't get rid of a
dislike
right and for a lot of people if they go
onto a youtube video and they realize oh
this person who uploaded this video is
getting rid of negative comments
well then the only other way i can
express how i feel about this video
is to hit the dislike button yeah and
and another thing is like
the way they framed it like they were
doing a solid for the creator
where the creator they they literally
said the creator can still see the dis
how many dislikes this video has right
so it doesn't help the creator at all
because they're the only ones
who can still see it right i i felt the
exact same way when
instagram got rid of publicly showing
how many likes a post has and yet the
creator can still see how many likes the
post has
i'm just like what's the difference at
that point like you're still putting
this like pressure on
the person putting it up right with
instagram i'd actually argue i think it
was a good thing i think it was a good
thing so yeah i think so
because i think instagram was like
highly competitively toxic
with likes and i guess maybe i didn't
think that way because i'm not
part of it yeah i'm i'm not a like
if you follow me on instagram i'm sorry
that there's just like
zero content and zero updates that's all
it's a dead account
really says a little win out of the
three of us i'm the most active on
instagram and yet i post like once a
month
i just like don't like the platform that
much and i think it used to be like the
likes was definitely a thing that i
didn't really
like at all to me that was like because
it because it really felt like people
would just like
farming and just like [ __ ] it it
really
bred this toxic kind of environment
where people were
it was literally like a cloud chasing
kind of platform well in question then
would you guys if twitter for example
implemented the same things instagram
did would you be okay with it
i would actually really i don't know i
felt like twitter is different
yeah right i don't i wouldn't want it on
twitter